c'est déjà venu à pas les noms dont les
riffs reid a son franc-parler vous
laisser faire bonjour madame
stéphane tard raconté que j'étais chez
les malades n'ont alors tu vas aller
faire tes valises situé ici je n'y suis
pour rien je peux être le mot même aux
jambes tu peux garder des gens mais tes
bras et regardé je pourrais pas l'autre
moment il va partir puis les ont jetés
renard mais moi aussi je t'emmerde
ben tu vois toi ça va mieux
oui
mais paris
goulon de petit déjeuner ou faire manger
du plastique un vrais croissants ça
s'achète dans une boulangerie où je fais
une tâche
ait un essai sera tenté par que ce
talent là j'aime trop mon corps pour
aller le fracasser sur un trottoir fait
tout pour qu'on croie avec mon mari
c'est l'homme qui a le plus compté dans
ma vie
on n'a plus personne en dehors de fruits
-
et
elle est là